let's talk about how insane people are
with this stuff because apparently the
only news is coveted news
all right there's this viral video this
one was awesome foul mouth delta
passenger who was arrested for spitting
at and punching 80 year old man for not
wearing a mask while he ate despite her
not wearing one either is revealed to be
a luxury real estate agent and former
raiderette man so he got space she spit
in his mouth in his mouth
all in the name for fighting kovitz
honestly i would pay good money to have
a raiderette spit in my life
hey hey family friendly hey that was a
completely rated
joke
that was that was that was good that was
that was one of my better ones thank you
i'm just gonna leave right now so that
was a good one so this lady is in this
viral video she's on the plane and
there's a guy's minding his own business
and he's like eating and she's screaming
at them wear yeah mask
why have people gone insane i think you
know what i think
misery loves company
this lady sees a guy sitting there not
wearing the mask and she thinks if i
have to wear it so does he and she gets
mad yup and so she goes up and starts
screaming at him and then the fbi
arrests her now she's going to go to
jail
there's another viral video where a guy
is stalking a woman in a supermarket and
he actually says is does anyone else has
anyone else pissed that we all have to
wear masks and she isn't
that's the mentality of these people
they are like children they're like well
if i have to you have to ah it's like
bro is anyone telling you to
they're not telling her to take your
mask off there's clearly no enforcement
well do you think it's that or you think
it's just that people who are really bad
at life suddenly have the opportunity to
exert power over others because i just i
s the people i see doing this like you
don't see dudes and i hate to be a bit
like i just i don't want this to sound
arrogant but you don't see dudes who are
built like me going up like put your
mask on no it's always little pipsqueaks
with really bad facial hair
it's really true so i think it gives
betas a chance to feel alpha because i
don't have the urge like i get to bark
at high school kids every day and say
get your [ __ ] you know i don't have the
urge to go and yell at someone without i
think it's lower than beta yeah yeah
well that's a part of that
that's part of the larger kind of
psychological conditioning that happened
because you saw the corporate media
repeat you could be a hero you could
save lives grandma could have an extra
year of life if you do your part if you
wear your mess and they heard that
message over and over again and they
also saw grandma and old people dying in
in horrible
horrific ways just broadcast to them 24
7 non-stop by the corporate media and
it's ingrained in their psychology that
if someone doesn't wear a mask they're
trying to kill me and this lady there's
reports of her being drunk whatever it
is i think was a victim of that larger
kind of mind control psychosis and and
she truly believed he's hurting someone
by not wearing a mask i think misery
loves company i think you have people
like bill maher he went on his show and
he was like i took one for the team i
got two shots and now they're saying i
gotta do more i'm not gonna do it
that's bill maher breaking out of the
mold yeah there's a lot of people who
are scared to so what ends up happening
is they get their third shot i've talked
to some people man and the reaction was
is is really
strange yes i was talking to someone
recently
about um restrictions vaccine mandates
in cities
and they i didn't say anything political
i was just like wow i mean it's going to
be you know i was like things are going
to get interesting with these mandates
and they're like who cares it's totally
fine it's totally it's it's totally no
big deal at all i've got all of my shots
and i was like all right like
that was that was a quick escalation
like there's an agitation in their voice
and my response was like yeah but you
know some places they're now saying like
you it's after nine months in germany or
whatever it doesn't matter i'll get it
i'll get it's fine and i'm like all
right slow down dude like what i'm
hearing in this is
there are people who are unsure of
themselves
and they're scared so they want to feel
comfort knowing everyone else is in the
same position they are
so when they say i went and did this
because i had to i don't know if it was
the right thing i'll feel better if
everyone else has to do the same thing
but people are refusing
i think what's happening is there are
people who don't want this is the danger
of the vaccine mandates especially when
bill de blasio goes on tv and says we're
going to tie your quality of life to the
mandate your paycheck to the mandate
there's going to be a dude i tell you
man this is what worries me they're
going to snap there's going to be a dude
who's like i don't want to do this i
know people who voted democrat who are
posting on facebook smack talking me
laughing and gloating and i people i
know
then the mandate started hitting for
their jobs and they're freaking out like
whoa whoa like what is going on do i
really have to do this this is freaking
me out
these people are freaking out
when you mandate someone get a medical
procedure and get something put in their
body and they don't feel good about it
this is going to cause a psychotic break
in someone they're going to have a
mental breakdown they're going to drop
to their knees screaming freaking out
because you've backed them into a corner
too much
you cannot push people beyond their
reasonable boundaries for this long and
this far
i used to work in nonprofit fundraising
we would go up to people on the street
and tell them sign up for our cause give
us your money one of the things i would
talk to people about is reasonable
boundaries can you get a person to do
something that is unreasonable the
answer is no it's very difficult it
takes time and conditioning after two
years
in a rapid pace people have now taken
three shots many of these people don't
get their flu shots they've not gotten
their booster shots they live their life
and they mind their own business but now
they're in a position where the
government is beating them down over and
over and over again what's happening
this woman on the airplane she snapped
she lost it she saw someone who is not
experiencing the pain she experiences
when the government forced her to do
this and she was angry why aren't you
suffering like me
and so she spits in his mouth
she walks up and she spit in his mouth
well he had his mouth open and she spit
into his face that's good aim right into
his like i was pretty close yeah yeah
and she was very close but i think this
is people who are feeling anxiety and
stress from the government forcing to do
things they don't have the courage to
say no and so when they see someone who
says no they get angry because that's a
reflection on them yeah you're too weak
they're not so they say if i have to
suffer you have to suffer with me
bertrand russell once said quote
collective fear stimulates herd instinct
and tends to produce ferocity towards
those who are not regarded as members of
the herd so that quote is very fitting
to a lot of what's happening right now
sociologically but i i think a lot of
people are just in this constant state
of anxiety paranoia fear of this larger
unknown and i think a lot of
you know people out there play on this
fear of the unknown because it works on
our imagination it works on our greatest
fears personally in our lives and i
think a lot of this has been codified by
a lot of the corporate media coverage
when you see what they're saying when
you see over and over again the
messaging that they're bringing out
there it's comply get on your knees do
as you're told or else the worst is
going to happen to you and that's a
message that is absolutely ridiculous
and absolutely one that not only induces
fear but destroys people's immune
systems at the same time but let's talk
about this trope
where you get a a grade school bully
and he's beaten up the young nerdy kid
and then the nerdy kid you know he's
walking one day and then he you know
he's outside of school and he sees the
bully and there's his dad
bullying him you've seen this trope
right the kid who's the bully is getting
bullied and because he can't stand up to
his dad he takes his anger out on other
people and makes him feel better about
himself that's what i think we're seeing
with people like this and all these
other videos it's people who are who
feel powerless who want to feel that
power so what do they do they join the
mob they grab a pitchfork and they
threaten and scream at you because it
makes it feel like they're in control
yeah and that i think both of our
theories are correct yeah i think you
have powerless and you have people at a
breaking point but you also have the
just a bad combination
of 80 year old guy and if you've ever
talked to an 80 year old man they just
don't care right like no don't tell i'm
80 years old you know with this woman
who's obviously over the top
power hungry telling him what to do you
had two people who are not going to
compromise
you had israel versus iraq you know what
i mean like you had no compromise right
there so here we go this dude's sitting
in his chair among his own business and
he's eating he's literally following the
guidelines because look i'll tell you
what like i'm on planes i don't know
this is a delta flight but on united
they say you have to take your map you
have to wear your mask between bites uh
they say that but i guess that's if
you're flying first class they give you
more leeway it's total classism
on the way on the way back from arizona
for my bodybuilding show the woman next
to me didn't have a mask on the whole
flight no drink no nothing i was like
well this is great so i took mine off so
i think that they do treat the glasses
differently um but nonetheless nobody
look man when i have food or a beverage
in front of me and i fly a lot my mask
is off because i'm not putting on my
chin because what if i dribble food like
that's just nasty and i'll be like look
lady like if i like dribble like there's
food in this mask i ain't got that many
of them so i don't know i think it's
just a horrible combination and um
united
i've heard some bad horror stories
america's been really great but united
was fine today they didn't do anything
crazy they're all scared at the end the
end of this the fact remains if you're
rich you're exempt yeah basically you
get a private jet well there's also ceos
of american airlines and southwest that
are requesting that we get rid of the
masks on plane mandates and they're
saying this is you know this is
ridiculous and they're making arguments
against the federal policy for masks on
planes i i think some i think people are
going to lose their minds i think
have you seen these photos and videos of
people at christmas in like what they're
called isolation bubbles oh yeah oh my
god this is happening bubble people
bubble people like bubble boy so there's
like a woman and they they built a frame
out of pvc pipe and then wrapped it in
plastic wrap and she's sitting in it and
they're like we're safe
dude
people are going to lose their
people are losing their minds that that
is losing their minds tim yeah
there's you can buy those plastic
tanning
like containers or whatever it's like a
wire frame it's kind of like a hamper
but it's bigger and you zip it open and
stand inside and spray tan and it
contains everything for you i know
there's a woman's there's a woman
sitting in one of those and she like
gives a thumbs up to the camera and it's
like you have lost your minds look if
you think you're sick you don't go to a
family gathering it's just that simple
like i i've i've had many family
gatherings where it's like oh yeah uh
joe can't call me he came down with the
flu it's like okay
but these people are living in this
world where some of them aren't even
sick there's one guy
and they were like he had he had a
potential close contact so he's staying
outside he had a van opened up the back
pulled up to the window and he's sitting
in his van eating so that he could be
there and i'm like
this is crazy your p people are losing
their minds but what happens
when
it's not just that people you know these
people have adopted this worldview
they're choosing this and they're
smiling as they do it
now there are people like this lady
they're not smiling as they do it
they're freaking out like i think we're
going to see someone lose their mind and
seriously hurt themselves or others
because they're going to just be like
i'm over this there's already been a lot
of suicide what happens when you get
what happens when someone snaps
remember that term going postal back in
the day yeah yeah you worked in the post
office they drove you to the brink
because they were such bad employers
we're basically going to see a bunch of
people quote unquote go postal and it
makes you kind of empathy for the people
who
are kind of losing their minds because
they went along with it now
unfortunately i live in tennessee like
we literally did 15 days where i live
we're like okay that's enough we didn't
die cool let's go yeah i mean we were
having in july of 2020
in our gym we had a shoulder to shoulder
packed event
and nobody cared and the cops were there
having fun with us like it was a good
time whereas i watch for me to travel
and to watch the news is like watching
some weird like movie because none of
that ish happens where i live
none of it happens in in williamson
county tennessee we'll see a little
glimpse of it we'll see an occasional
weirdo but at the end of the day man
we're just we have wrestling tournaments
it's packed out here at the casino you
can still smoke indoors
people are smoking all over the place
it's like it's the 1990s there's no
there's no what uh when all this was
first starting you'd go there and they
had plastic put up at every table game
and it was it was really weird the funny
thing is apparently with the dividers up
people were betting on the don't pass
line so for those that aren't familiar
with craps oh my god are you familiar
with crabs yeah so typically people bet
on what's called the pass line you're
betting for the guy who's rolling the
person rolling the die to win
but the don't pass line betting on them
to lose is a slightly better bet
typically people don't do that because
it's kind of a dick move but when the
dividers went up people were like i
don't care you're like you're separated
from me you can get mad like people just
didn't care it was a weird thing it
really really separated us but now out
here it's all over it's been over for a
long time there's there's there's no
mandates but there are still businesses
because we're close to dc that are
engaging in this you can tell they're
more left-leaning you go you go into
west virginia and people are going to be
like huh
like it doesn't exist you know people
are just doing their thing a lot of
people have characterized it as
sanitation theater as there is some
preliminary data showing that it was
absolutely almost pointless when it
comes to quote stopping the spread and
again
there's not a lot of science here
there's not a lot of data why aren't we
collecting the data why aren't we
investigating a lot of thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you